hallo ich ihn liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy zusammen mit
paletten stinkt so hast du dich in teams
bei kindern anders
du hast dich da noch immer noch mal was
bitteres reingeschrieben so ist man
darauf auch formieren hat geht jetzt
heute bei dir hallo von mir mit bei dir
ja bei mir geht gerade ich weiß gar
nicht genau was ich machen soll
weil ich ja in der letzten folge ist
schon eine komische weapons boxee
bekommen hat und in der ak 7 40 gebaut
habe ich wollte eventuell auf creeper
jagd gehen
commander krieger ist drauf ganz alleine
den tag
also ich denke ich werde erstmal wir
versuchen wir versuchen nicht erst mal
versuchen per twitter zu töten
dass ich eine munition für meine aka 740
machen kann und dann wollte ich auch mir
eventuell in wenn man mit den leuten
zusammen so eine art baans portal machen
dass wir ein wenig uns teleportieren
können dass ich werde mal in die stadt
von leben kann und palmen in unserer
stadt damit das wundervoll genau nicht
wert heute mal versuchen meinen drachen
zumindest in die richtigen bahnen zu
lenken ich glaube ich werde mal bei
kevins in meter gehen ich hoffe das ist
jetzt hier kein kein fehlschlag
ich brauche unbedingt lava für den
feuerdrachen den ich melde mich jetzt
nacken werde
ach ja das wollte ich auch machen ich
wollte auch in nein was hat er mit dem
portal gemacht wieso ist das nicht mehr
so funktioniert das nicht mehr deshalb
tue ich jetzt das wirft meine kompletten
pläne über bord aber das ist gar kein
problem
juhu oder und ist ein krieg natürlich
erst einmal hinten sich lieber auf mich
ist
stimmt hättest inc ich bin ja so blöd
ich will den privaten und es gelingt mir
einfach nicht
ich habe jetzt ein kleines problem
online jetzt bin ich ein krieg ja auch
verdammt stimmt ich will mich aber nicht
immer verwandeln wie kann ich das in
umstellen
ich komme jetzt nur die laber junge er
drückt drücken der links neben der
return -taste wollitz lag ich hier
unseren tollen lava vulkan
ja ja das ist mir auch bewusst aber ich
will nicht immer mich umwandeln dürfen
wenn ich jemanden tötet ist beim ersten
mal töten
funktioniert das immer dann verwandelt
man sich aber danach ist dann ende
gelände brauche auch noch palmen gut
glaube ich dass ich mein haus bauen ja
das ist und ich habe so ein buch das ich
einfach mal angucken das bei euch ist
beim kunst ist zwar keine richtige stadt
weil alle irgendwie so weit auseinander
leben
wie sieht es bei euch habt ihr euch
zusammengebaut irgendwie ne wir sind
auch alle sollen so ein bisschen
verstreut ich kann so ein bisschen auch
stoffels haus gucken auf das von caprivi
und die broken sumpf jungs wohnen das
weiß ich gar nicht so recht
bei mir ist es auch so ich weiß wo ich
selbst wohne allerdings wirklich gut
allerdings ich kann auf das auf die
insel von telos kann ich schauen und ich
kann da hinschauen muss berg wohnt aber
sonst auch nicht ungewohnt allerdings
weit auseinander ich hätte das folgen
zum nächsten verknüpfen dass das ganze
dann irgendwie so mit ein paar kilos ich
wollt uns der hängebrücke zueinander
bauen ein paar coole sachen aber sonst
alle anderen wurden voll wald werde
sowohl schade und bei mir geht gerade
die wunderschöne minecraft wo sie kann
dich mal kurz ausstellen muss er geht
kann die sonne auf oder warum geht die
an
ich weiß nicht ich hatte die auswahl
setzt sich eintracht natürlich nicht
komplett darum ich weiß nicht ob das
funktioniert hier
und mir meinen drachen ein wenn wir
sehen dass sich das verwandelt ach du
hast schon drachen
also brauchen doch momentan ist es noch
iphone
aber bald wird es sein iphone hinten
halten kein iphone noch in einer lösung
iphone in minecraft gerade das ziemlich
eis und nahm eine komische behälter
verbrennt so hoch also jetzt hab ich
noch keinen drachen sondern einfach nur
noch ein iphone sagt er ist er mal
gucken was daraus bilden das ist immer
so ein bisschen doof wenn man so in zwei
verschiedenen städten wurden dann so
miteinander kommentiert er
man redet immer ein anderen aneinander
vorbei ein bisschen sah
entweder muss wieder abgeschossen es ist
okay ich sterbe ach so an hunger ich
wollte schon sagen hey you was ich
nämlich auch sagen wollte ist der
verlobte der ist ja mal ganz gern
so hat das gras und klitzekleinen lag in
der stimme ich dachte ich richtig war
die ganze zeit vom 18
unsere fleisch zu essen dadurch müssen
also wo ich hat stehen geblieben war war
ich wollte sagen das ja immer mal live
streams machst michael galaxy können ja
überhaupt sehr gern mal auf checken und
ich würde das ganze halt auch nie gern
machen allerdings ist mein internet
zurzeit noch total volk nicht mit einer
mülltonne immer noch behindern
und deswegen werde ich erst eine neue
leitung bekommen wenn die ungesunde nach
hamburg übrigens zum valuten hamburgs
sündiger dann
treffen wir uns der alltägliche treffen
dann ein paar videos zusammen jedenfalls
kann ich nicht leben zurzeit noch nicht
und deswegen ist einem die möglichkeit
geben dass man eine 1 stunden folge darf
grobleben hat genau und das ganze wollte
ich dann eventuell was haltet ihr davon
also da würde ich jetzt fahren das geht
irgendwie mal über die abstimmen
funktionen also über die der zombie hat
gerade was fallen lassen
auch im rucksack rockstar und backpacker
läuft bei dir
er ist sehr schön zu gucken hier
ich gucke immer auf meinen college block
was sich so alles hier bauen muss red
storm transco oder unten kommt dann noch
ein bisschen redstone hin
und jetzt fehlt mir also kommt sagt
jawohl da ist doch endlich des team
dynamo jeder ja stark wird einfach mal
so einfach fallen lassen so schön soll
ich muss einfach noch ein paar kicker
tut mir so ein bisschen dampf oder holen
aber die menschen töten mitmachen kann
ich bin auch zu blöd diese kiefer zu
töten das jetzt gerade noch ein dickeres
problem ein maschinenschlosser
weggeflogen die letzte folge wo ich da
so ein schönes sind schön bak hatte von
meinem texture pack natürlich ein
bisschen problematisch was du bist weg
geflogen
ich bin nicht weggeflogen aber ich hatte
ja nun was der planung das war einfach
das bedürfnis der geflogen
35 das was kraft hast du denn her schuss
munition für meine waffe a stehen da
bist du ja so aktiv stimmen da brauche
ich auch noch mal diese blöde box da
habe ich auch noch genügend kaktus green
sind die leute bei mir so ein bisschen
ausgerastet dass ich mir die ich gemacht
habe leute die sind ja erst mal beim
pulver reiser wir wollen advance
genetics voranbringen ja ich wollte mich
da auch mal ganz gern beschäftigen bei
uns damals in mega projekt war das ja so
dass wir das war nicht die mode sondern
das war eine modifikation
wo ich weiß als ich vom pulver reiser
den kenne ich noch aber da war noch so
dinge hinzugefügt die ich hier noch
nicht gefunden habe und zwar das mit den
pips also dass man so gut pipe sondern
kann man items transportieren und so was
alles ich glaube diese modifikation ist
auf diesem in diesem motto pack leider
nicht waren und das hat das einzige
woran ich mich auskenne
das ok um auf technik und sonst versuche
ich mich da ganz langsam heran zu tasten
ich glaube dieser flügel zur iaa sehr
blöde luggage der snack immer meine
sachen dates wo sind denn diese
kopfsache nämlich flogen daraus hat sich
allerdings jetzt wird daraus august ich
bin so blöd das los ich kann keine
creeper töten
das zeigt dass ruckelt immer so ein
bisschen wenn ich als fledermaus und
creeper töte ich bin nämlich jetzt
zurück in mich selbst superreiche
ich fliege gerade was wenn ich mich dann
zurückverwandelt sag mal wie viel
minuten sind wir denn dual der fall da
wir sind bei 83 oder kann ich ja normal
reli lose und bisschen ein bisschen
feuerstein besorgen dass er trotz war
das ist echt bitter dass hier einfach
jetzt die ganzen trieb er alle tot weil
wird ich finds ja echt cool wenn sie in
so einer modifikation gibt das ist so
richtig das ist bei euch gerade nacht
will weiß bonns tag wird sowie an welt
seite aber so weit sind wir doch glaube
ich nicht voneinander entfernt aber ich
weiß schon was du meinst es wäre echt
cool aber man kann nicht alles haben
was einspruchs leben ist kein ponyhof
oder scrabble und am 03
oder kann ich nicht in die anden auf
einen anderen weg gunpowder mehr
beschaffen weiße bitte die kommentare
jetzt kann ich mir dieser folge wieder
gerade patronen machen
ich hatte soviel creeper gefunden aber
ich konnte einfach nur ein viertel töten
weil es beim rest ihn geruckelt hat ich
habe aber auch schon seinen coolen spiel
gemacht ich kann mich eigentlich drauf
setzen anfahren oder freiheit stand for
genetic is temporarily disabled priester
und da steht einfach keinen grund die
durstes und stuhl gemacht
ja ja der desktop kraft also muss ich es
musste so eine ananas die holen
ich hab mal anders und du brauchst auch
noch sollen soll pina colada und snacks
und in pina colada allen dann werde ich
da hinten portiert gehen aber auch man
verdammt ich dachte ich könnte mir den
hier auch hinstellen das hab ich
bestimmt wieder alle die kommentare
geschrieben
du bist ja so bluten der planung von in
frankreich ich bin einmal habe ich den
großen fehler gemacht wollte kakteen
suchen und dann bin ich über so ein paar
drüber geflogen und dann war das schon
wieder in den kommentaren für die leute
ausgelastet sich das doch bitte beim
nächsten mal besser machen soll
brille fielmann dass das war jetzt
wirklich die richtige wahl
sogar eine brille ich habe sogar eine
brille habe ich sie nie auf ich will ich
will sehr gern eine sehschwäche hätte
gerne brülle ich finde brüllen sie
mittlerweile richtig schön aus okay es
gibt mittlerweile so schöne brillen die
man sich einfach kaufen kann dann zieht
man richtig klug mit aus richtig klug
weil ansonsten richtig richtig los also
ich fände es sich im wasser ist auch
immer die frage ob man so der typ ist
keine brille
ich bin ich bin das 27 auf einen
leidenschaftlicher sie wollte schon
sagen sonnen träger ja ich sag immer die
sonne sonnenbrillenträger also irgendwie
trat voll auf einfach eine sonnenbrille
und deshalb meine ich hatte denn die
habe ich aber dann vor ein paar tagen
auf dem festival verloren
ach ja ok wir weisen mit dem bruder
umgeschmissen hast ja holy festival ich
ohne spaß
ich gucke auf meinem handy am nächsten
tag und ich hab da so viele fotos darauf
gefunden wo ich diese sonnenbrille hut
aufhat nicht weiter unten weiter unten
und ich mag es einfach nicht mehr auf
also wirklich einfach weg das war so
traurig so durch sondern wurde weg aber
ich habe nicht gefilmt video oder
irgendwie so wo die bill weggenommen
wurde da verdi hat ich hoffe immer noch
dass irgendwer die irgendwo abgibt und
ich dir irgendwann weil irgendwo
wiederfinden sollte aber das ist viel zu
viel irgend und das wird das wird
niemals personen erwachsene etwas mehr
wird er oder wav fernsehen machen gerade
so ein bisschen ein bisschen
schleichwerbung für fühlt aber andere
sind auch super leute brille gesehen hat
auch die tollsten sachen viele und
welche sachen gibt es da noch alles ich
habe keine ahnung ich weiß auch nicht
was es für andere brille der stelle
neben red band gibt weg zu alle die die
ganzen gucci und die manuale brillen
dinge die man sich auch kauft cembalo
die leute dass das kein h&m und so weiß
es ist alles hier der fall ist wird bei
mir auch hier alles was was wobei mir
auch draufsteht dass es nicht irgendwie
nur editors ist eigentlich habe ich will
ja nicht so als monster da stehen auf
youtube money muss man natürlich ein
bisschen geheim halten genauso wie wir
jetzt auch die folge nicht geheim halten
aber jetzt beenden weil die zeit sich
langsam schon dem ende handelt kann
nicht wahr sein aber wartet bevor wir
die folge beenden
also macht es nochmal hier nochmal sein
sein dynamo hin
zack und damit ist der pulver plus
dynamo fertig das drachen eingeblendet
ich klicke auf disconnect ich mache das
auch eben natürlich sagen es euch
gefallen hat können wir uns das gerne
über die bewertungsfunktion mitteilen
sonst kommt morgen noch eine folge mit
bluten wenn er jetzt nicht irgendwie
ganz dringende termine also ich muss
noch mal mein bett bekommen
nach der auf von gucci ist